is the neighborhood and you are not
welcome
that's why I need to be here
[Music]
hold open people I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Reuben report it's March 13 2023 we
are live at a special time today that's
right you don't suffer from time shift
disorder you haven't had a stroke or any
other sort of medical emergency we're
actually a little bit late today a
couple hours postponed because I was at
an event in West Palm Beach this morning
with Governor DeSantis he was laying out
his whole diversity equity and inclusion
policy and how we are going to remove it
from every single institution in the
Free State of Florida we were focused
mostly on education institutions but
it's going to be it's going to be
removed from absolutely everything so I
was over there we'll have some clips for
you tomorrow I did have a few minutes in
a little private session with a couple
other people with the governor after and
uh makes you wonder if I learned any
other information
we're live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and locals by the way if you want to
join us for the post game show or if you
want to correct me at any commentary or
query me on something that's on your
mind you can join us at
reubenreport.locals.com we're also
taking the locals crew our paid
subscribers we're taking a whole bunch
of you guys to Washington DC in about a
week and a half we're going to go meet
with Kevin McCarthy we're going to
wander around the mall together we're
going to take a tour of the Capitol
maybe we'll have some tequila or
whatever your drink of choices it's
going to be a fine fine situation but
today ladies and gentlemen we must talk
about the complete ridiculous buffoons
that are running this government because
in case you haven't heard you probably
have because I have the smartest
audience online I believe there was a
Pew study that proved that Silicon
Valley Bank has failed and now Signature
Bank has also failed Signature Bank
which I did not know until this morning
the head of Signature Bank Barney Frank
if there's one good thing for
progressives there's one good thing
progressives are good that it's
destroying things but Silicon Valley
Bank you may not be part of Silicon
Valley Bank you may think I'm not part
of Silicon Valley I don't care about
Silicon Valley Bank I don't care about
any of this stuff but when Banks fail
and then particularly when the
government comes in and bails them out
which is exactly what has happened as of
this morning there are actual systemic
repercussions throughout the system
that's the correct use of systemic
people always say systemic racism which
does not exist that means it's baked
into the system but the systemic
repercussions when One Bank fails and
then we bail them out or this Bank fails
and we don't do anything and before I do
anything on the show today
I want to say two things first off I am
not a financial expert okay I'm pretty
good with my finances actually there
were times in my life that I was in debt
there were times in my life I owed money
to the government for taxes but I got
two businesses now that are completely
in the black I I run these things
responsibly which is how I run my life
and I think if the government did that
sort of thing not that I'm some sort of
Genius but I don't spend what I don't
have I try to invest properly and and I
believe in property and things of that
nature if we all did what we are
supposed to do then we wouldn't have a
government that is completely running
out of control that's one thing at the
micro level just sort of how it really
does all of this starts with us because
the people that are in charge right now
are the people that we voted for maybe
not in this specific case of this
Administration if you're watching this
but we do put these people into power
and then they do all of these crazy
things but the second thing I want to
say and then and then we'll get into it
and this is also related to the debt
ceiling fight which is happening and
much more
is that I'm also not going to pretend
that there's only one answer to all of
this I'm going to actually play a couple
videos and read a couple statements from
people that I really like that have been
on this show that have completely
opposing views on this stuff so Vivek
ramaswamy who is running for president
who is a good dude who is fighting ESG
at the highest possible levels uh he has
a certain take on this thing David sacks
former CEO of PayPal who invested in
locals who is a huge Silicon Valley
investor he had a different take on it
I'm going to try to compare and contrast
them and then and then hopefully you'll
be able to make some decisions for
yourself but the point here is the
government somehow always gets bigger
the the house seems to always win and
those of us who act responsibly
personally in our lives in our
businesses Etc seem to always foot the
bill for everyone else so whether it's
inflate stationary spending or the debt
ceiling endlessly going or the interest
rates going higher or the bank runs that
inevitably will be coming if we let the
whole thing fail the problem is that it
always comes back to us when they tell
us it ain't going to cost you anymore uh
yeah the money has to come from
somewhere so that is the uh the base
level version of the show today before
we get to it I want to talk to you guys
about moink box because you may want
some meat at the end of the day like
today did you guys know that 60 of U.S
pork production comes from one company
owned by the Chinese and their Hogs are
given something called ractopamine which
is banned in 160 countries including
China yet you find it in your grocery
aisle every day well guys there's a
better way I want to tell you about
moink that's moo plus oink as you know
Moy delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and sustainable wild
caught Alaskan salmon straight to your
door you choose the meat delivered in
every box like Ribeyes chicken breast
pork chops to Salmon plays and much more
plus he can cancel any time there's
nothing better than cooking their meats
on my green egg on a Friday evening
Shark Tank host Kevin O'Leary called
moink's bacon the best bacon he's ever
had plus they guarantee you'll say oink
oink I'm just so happy I got moaked keep
American farming going by signing up at
moinkbox.com Reuben right now and
listeners of this show get free filet
mignon in every order for a year that's
one of the best filet mignon you'll ever
taste but for a limited time
m-o-i-n-k box.com
reubenmoitbox.com Reuben and now back to
me okay so the big situation right now
obviously is the Silicon Valley Bank
collapse and just within the last few
hours we have found out that the
government is going to come in and save
them before I get to all of that what
was leading up to all of this over the
last week is that there has been a
massive fight over the debt ceiling now
the Layman's way of explaining the Dead
Sea feeling is that we the United States
are a debtor Nation we don't really have
any money it's not because we don't take
in enough money it's because the
government always spends way more than
it takes in so our debt goes up every
year and at some point the creditors go
boy you owe us a couple trillion dollars
we'd like to buy lunch today could we
get some of that back and we don't then
we don't want to give it to them so then
we borrow more money So eventually you
hit the debt ceiling now those of you
that have a credit card you know about
this whether you're 18 and your credit
card limit is 500 or whether you're
doing pretty well and your credit card
limit is you know twenty thirty thousand
dollars when you hit the limit
if you pop the credit card in the
machine or you tap it on the thing with
the tap tap uh if you've hit the limit
you're done there's nothing they're
going to do for you you can't borrow
more than they've allowed but with the
government it can always borrow more and
it never matters how much they take in
you could give them everything in the
world they're always going to want to
spend more so the debt limit which we
hit this thing every couple years is
that is where we're supposed to stop
we've hit the place we're supposed to
stop we can't borrow more and then what
do the government people do Democrats
and Republicans we always add to the
debt ceiling and how do they get us to
do it well they tell us that if you
don't add to the debt ceiling you're
going to screw over the full faith and
credit of the United States of America I
don't know who's believing in this faith
and credit anymore but in any event
that's what's happening right now
there's been this fight over the debt
ceiling I would again make a point of
saying this is a bipartisan ridiculous
issue there's a few exceptions to this
Rand Paul always fights it Ted Cruz is
forwarded over the years Thomas Massey I
mean the the true libertarian types
fight this thing you can't just always
increase that pretty much everyone else
is always into it anyway here is uh
White House Office of Management and
budget director Shalonda young and she's
talking about the debt ceiling and how
it shouldn't be tied to anything like
spending huh
you're talking about House Republicans
obviously that has been a big point of
debate with them from the house Freedom
caucus we saw them unveil when it comes
to their proposals for the debt ceiling
crisis which we're facing because
there's no agreement so far between the
White House and Republicans what we saw
from them was essentially arguing that
they have 10 demands or so that they say
must be included in the in the agreement
for raising the debt ceiling do you
agree with anything that they've put
forward from the house Freedom caucus we
believe strongly the debt ceiling should
not be tied uh to any other discussions
that is constant the congress's
Constitutional duty to raise the debt
ceiling they did it three times for the
former president
it is not congress's constitutional duty
to raise the debt ceiling that is not in
the Constitution but let's put that
aside lady what this is all about is the
endless spending right it's that again
just just really lock this in your head
we take in a certain amount of money
right the government taxes people
it takes in a certain amount and it just
spins in spans and spends and it spends
so much that it ends up printing money
thus deflating the value of the money
that it took in oh on top of the fact
that we give countries like say Ukraine
120 billion dollars while we cut Aid to
our hurricane victims uh in Southwest
Florida or if there's a giant chemical
spill let's say in East Palestine Ohio
we do that and then they just want to
keep moving it and they scare the hell
out of you they say but if we don't
raise the debt ceiling the government
will shut down now from where I'm
sitting I would love a government
shutdown how about you people shut down
and just don't come back the thing is
they always uh scare you with that and
then they very rarely do it we've had a
couple a couple government shutdowns
over the last 20 30 years they last for
like a week they get rid of you know we
can't take a tour of the White House a
couple other little things but it's like
I think they realize now if they shut
down a whole bunch of us 10 days in
would be like who what we didn't need
those people anyway uh the way that
they're framing the question in this
interview on CNN it's like oh but those
Freedom caucus guys they want to tie the
debt ceiling to some stuff yes because
the freedom caucus guys people like chip
Roy
and Thomas Massey are like well if
you're just going to keep getting us
into debt could we we've got these
demands here we'd like you to maybe cut
you know about lunches at the uh
commissary in the capital or we're going
to spend a little bit less on that like
I don't even know what the 10 demands
are the point is all they're saying is
hey we'll sign on to this never-ending
catastrophic Ridiculousness but could we
get a little something back could we
just not endlessly spend like drunken
Sailors and then of course what the
white house uh spokeswoman I assume
she's a woman I'm not a scientist what
she does over there is basically like no
they're they're constitutional Duty they
have to do it
ah all right we're gonna go over to
Colbert next all right now to cold bear
and then we'll go back to Shalonda in
just a second here's how Stephen Colbert
who at this point is nothing other than
a regime propagandist quote unquote
comedian is covering the fight over the
debt ceiling
the GOP quickly rejected Biden's budget
because they preferred deep cuts to
Health Care food assistance and housing
programs for poor Americans yes
now now it just reflects the Bedrock
judeo-christian values of the Republican
party and and Echoes the words of Our
Lord for I was hungry and you said hey
who gave you that free food slap that
fish out of his dirty little mouth
yeah yeah that's great Colbert 20 Riders
all getting paid for that those people
should not be able to cash their checks
you know there's going to be other
people if Bank fails if banks fail that
they can't cash their checks those
writers should not be getting paid a
cent uh to be clear if you want to
understand how they launder the lies
that's a phrase I often use here it's
like they print something in the New
York Times that Republicans want to cut
food programs and they want to cut
housing assistance Republicans are scary
and then he just repeats that nonsense
with a glib joke the Republicans
generally speaking
we have a stupid party and an evil party
that's a Peter deal line I've heard him
say a couple times the evil party is
obviously the Democrats and the
Republicans are the stupid party but the
Republicans are a little less evil right
being stupid I can work with evil is
tough to work with so yes they do want
to cut a whole bunch of things if you
actually endlessly give people money uh
and give people food and give people
housing maybe that's going to keep
people in a cycle of poverty Thomas Soul
101 stuff so yes Republicans do want to
cut a couple things so they're a little
bit better I would say in this instance
but okay that's how mainstream
quote-unquote comedy is dealing it
dealing with it now back to shalanda
Young uh here she is with Cecilia Rouse
and they are discussing their press
conference about this whole thing and
they basically admit they have no plans
to save Social Security and they don't
know what to do because inflation's
outpaging wage growth but the important
thing people and just this is the
important thing when you're watching
this clip these are women of color and
do not criticize them otherwise you're a
bigot
the thinking is that Social Security
only has about 12 more years of solvency
left this seems like a good opportunity
isn't it with divided government for the
president to make a proposal hope for a
compromise he doesn't seem to be
interested in doing that well you assume
the debate is from cutting no benefits
and moving forward we're trying to
protect the benefits that are there now
I wish we were at the point of the
debate
where we could sit down and come up with
proposals to extend uh unfortunately
it is clear that some people want to go
backwards so I'm going to ask about the
other thing today the jobs report uh if
I could so the average hourly wages in
the jobs report is up 4.6 percent the
CPI inflation is 6.4 percent that it's
inflation has been outpacing wages for
about a year and a half when can
Americans expect that to reverse relief
from that so um we did see that on an
annual basis we saw uh some wage uh the
nominal wages went up lower than what we
expect
I was being slightly facetious that if
you criticize those women that you're a
bigot but in actuality the Optics of
that are just that they purposely put
these people up there because they know
a certain segment of society will listen
to that nonsense but be afraid to
criticize it because nobody wants to be
called a homophobe because Corinne
Jean-Pierre is a lesbian a bigot because
the other women are dark-skinned etc etc
but they are completely incompetent it
is because of the insolvency of Social
Security and the growth of inflation
that this Administration has been for
endlessly printing money endlessly
causing the cost of goods to go up and
then screwing up the supply chain and
everything else that the the debt
ceiling debate has been sparked right
like we go through this every couple
years but we have a special version of
it right now because we have a
government that believes you can just
print money relentlessly and if you
print money relentlessly eventually guys
if you took any basic class in any basic
school at any basic age supply and
demand and if you just pump something it
becomes worthless but the debt that
we're now in has led to higher rates
which has led to a whole bunch of new
data points there's a lot of problems
right now uh and mainly it's that wages
and jobs are slowing down that's kind of
the important thing when it comes to the
economy uh here's Fox Business on just
that
they had a better outlet they had a
better way they had a better path to
getting more money and having a better
life and I think that's cut off for now
the important point that you're making
here and that all of you are making
because one of the standouts in this
report is a weak wage number
all right so when wages slow down right
then people stop working as hard they
stop looking for work right then you
stop buying as much stuff and you stop
buying as much stuff and then they stop
producing as much stuff and this is all
obviously linked to the fact that our
economic policies have actually been
designed I believe it I've had enough of
people saying oh they intend their
intentions are good the road to hell is
paved with good intentions these people
who have been focused on diversity and
equity and inclusion and who have been
focused on everything other than doing
what their actual jobs are they have led
us to this very moment that is not to
say that the people in charge of Silicon
Valley Bank didn't do speculative
lending and didn't take crazy risks they
shouldn't have taken we'll get more into
that in just a second but it's against
the backdrop of a government that is run
by a bunch of crazy children so Federal
fund rates are increased so that we can
reel in inflation and reduce our debt
once the rates go up then it makes it
more expensive to borrow which thus
means it is harder for companies to hire
more people increase their wages and pay
back their debt so with all of that in
mind I'm trying to do this in a somewhat
a somewhat simplistic fashion so because
I know that the economic stuff it's not
even my favorite stuff either but but we
need to know the basics on this and and
the fill the philosophic underpinnings
behind all of the all of what happened
because as I'm about to get to there are
good people on on every side of this
debate when it comes to to the bailouts
and what we should do now so first off
here is uh this is was live on ABC as
Silicon Valley Bank was failing
as we come on the air this morning the
federal government is scrambling to
contain the Fallout over the collapse of
Silicon Valley Bank the largest U.S Bank
to fail since the 2008 financial crisis
the second biggest bank to collapse in
U.S history Silicon Valley Bank
primarily catered to startups and
technology companies but its demise
began Wednesday after concern over its
cash reserves sparked a bank run by its
clients the Federal Deposit Insurance
Corporation has taken control of the
bank and it's billions of dollars in
deposits the vast majority of which is
not insured okay so there's a couple
things here on the last point that she
made about the vast majority not being
insured as you guys know when you
deposit when you used to go to the bank
nobody goes to a bank anymore but
remember back in the day you'd go to the
bank hand them some cash or give them a
couple checks sign your name on the back
the whole thing and then you'd see FDIC
insured that the federal government will
ensure up to I always a 200 or 250 000
it's 250 right okay that the federal
government will ensure what you put in
the bank up to 250 meaning if the bank
then takes your money because what a
bank does with your money is it invests
with it it does things with it hoping
that it can turn a profit on your money
what the bank doesn't want is everybody
at the same time taking all their money
out because they don't have that cash
just sitting there they have it in other
Investments and sometimes those
Investments are highly speculative and
risky now what's interesting about
Silicon Valley Banks specifically is as
she said uh it was a startup and tech
company bank for the most part so
startups and tech companies these are
highly volatile many of them run at a
major loss for many many years many of
them are overvalued I can tell you as a
guy that started locals at first I was
putting a lot of money in I was working
for free we scrapped together whatever
we could we got a couple investors over
time we were running at a deficit that's
that's how it's done right you don't
just make if you have a great idea and a
great product you can't just make money
the next day maybe if you're selling
salad dressing or something right out of
your the back of your truck but like for
the most part you have to build a
company hire a whole bunch of good
engineers and Architects and software
people and figure all this stuff out so
you run at a deficit with the hope of
then at some point you will have enough
users and data and everything else and
then hopefully income too uh to then
Spike this thing for us it worked out
because then we found a company that had
incredible distribution in this case
Rumble we merged together we had
subscriptions they had the
infrastructure so it all made sense and
we all and we stayed within our means
and the rest of it but it should not
come as like some crazy massive surprise
that Silicon Valley Bank which was
lending to companies that often don't
bring a whole bunch of money in suddenly
realize wow a lot of these companies are
failing and they made other Investments
that made no sense so the collapse of
Silicon Valley Bank is a result of bad
but legal you have to understand this as
far as we know legal investment
decisions but what that sits next to is
the high interest rates on their debt
because of government spending so the
money that they had became worth less
and then some people were like hey can
we get our cash and they were like ah
cash why would you want cash here's a
little more from CNBC
Silicon Valley Bank the 16th biggest
bank in the U.S at the start of last
week had been operational for 40 years
and was considered a reliable source of
funding for Tech startups and Venture
Capital firms the california-based
commercial lender was a subsidiary of
svb Financial Group and with silicon
Valley's largest bank by deposits svb
Financial groups holding Holdings assets
such as U.S treasury and
government-backed mortgage Securities
viewed as safe were hit by and here's
the key part by the fed's aggressive
interest rate hikes and their value
dropped dramatically the company's
Tipping Point came on Wednesday when svb
announced it had sold 21 billion dollars
worth of its Securities at a roughly 1.8
billion dollar loss and said it needed
to raise 2.25 billion to meet clients
withdrawal needs and fund new lending
that new Senate stock price plunging and
triggered a panic-induced wave of
withdrawals from VCS and other
depositors within a day Silicon Valley
Bank stock had tanked 60 and led to a
loss of more than 80 billion in Bank
shares globally okay so in layman's
terms
while they were doing some risky and
speculative lending to these VCS and to
these other Silicon Valley companies
that as I said you just don't know if
these companies are going to make it
many many of them they borrow a ton of
money and they just they go Belly Up
but it also had to do with the
government that has caused interest
rates to rise that has devalued the
dollar so the point is they bought
Securities at a good price during the
pandemic then inflation goes nuts
interest rate goes nuts and then they
realize they're looking at the books
going oh man we are seriously screwed
right now so let's go back to Shalonda
young I like this name Shalonda young
and here's shawanda young uh and here's
well I guess this isn't great news by
Shalonda young you know what it reminds
me of Shalon I know you guys are from
New York there was a woman who used to
do the lottery I think on channel 11.
her name was Yolanda Vega someone will
get this reference and here's Yolanda
Vega with the lottery numbers for
tonight here's Shalonda young telling us
that the system is unsafe and unsecure
so you can't tell the American people
this morning because I think this has
caused a lot of concern that the U.S
banking system is safe and secure I
think the The Voice here uh is our
treasury secretary who is our lead and
working with Regulators that's
appropriate uh person uh we should
listen to here and who's tracking this
the most closely but again what I will
say is after the financial crisis the
reforms put in place
um have given Regulators more Tools in
our system is more resilient in the
foundation stronger because of it okay
this is absolutely hilarious we're going
to show you what Janet Yellen that's who
she's talking about Janet Yellen is the
head of the FED right what she's
referring to in just a second but I
realized as I was watching that clip I'm
so blessed I want to say guys I'm so
blessed to work with such wonderful
people because you all do your job you
all do your job and in the government no
one does their job and everyone just
points to somebody else and nobody knows
how to do anything when I show up at
work in the morning people are doing
their job I don't even know what some of
your jobs are but I know you you're
doing them because I'm able to do my job
okay God only knows what you're doing
right now Daphne's typing I don't know
what you're doing but you're doing
something is it work related
it's work related okay very exciting you
you could run the whole freaking federal
government so what's Janet Yellen been
up to over here right because uh that's
that's who you along to wait not Yolanda
what's her name again
I got Yolanda Vega confused with
Shalonda Young
I hope Yolanda Vega is still out there
anyway uh watch this so here's what
Johnny Allen here's here's how on the
ball Janet Yellen is about this whole
thing these two tweets that I'm about to
show you are eight hours apart uh the
first one treasury secretary uh Janet
Yellen rules out of bailout for Silicon
Valley Bank we're not going to do that
again she said and by again of course
she's referring to 2008 where we bailed
out all these Banks and we said the
banks are too big to fail so we just
ended up with bigger Banks eight hours
later is the information we're giving
you on the right there joint statement
from Powell Yellen and grubenberg
Silicon Valley Bank has been resolved
and fully protects all depositors
depositors will have access to all of
their money tomorrow New York Signature
Bank has been closed full statement here
so eight hours before we're not bailing
out anybody
eight hours later bail them out these
are the people that are in charge it is
just incredible this morning they woke
up Joe Biden they got him out of the
coffin they Juiced him up with God knows
what although it didn't fully take us
you'll see by his energy here and he
explained a little bit more as to what's
going on
on Friday the government regulator in
charge the FDIC took control of Silicon
Valley Bank's assets and over the
weekend it took control of signature
Banks assets
treasury secretary Yellen and a team of
banking Regulators have taken action
immediate action and here are the
highlights first all customers who had
deposits in these Banks can rest assured
I want to rest assured they'll be
protected and they'll have access to
their money as of today second the
management of these banks will be fired
if the bank is taken over by FDIC the
people running the bank should not work
there anymore
third investors in the banks will not be
protected
they knowingly took a risk and when the
risk didn't pay off investors lose their
money that's how capitalism works
and fourth there are important questions
of how these Banks got into the
circumstance in the first place
we must get the full accounting of what
happened and why those responsible can
be held accountable I'm going to ask
Congress and the banking Regulators to
strengthen the rules for banks to make
it less likely this kind of bag failure
would happen again and to protect
American jobs and small businesses
look the bottom line is this Americans
can rest assured that our banking system
is safe your deposit look
the bottom line is this Americans can
rest assured if you think that man has
any clue as to what he's talking about
you should seek help uh first off they
clearly just woke him up for that is
that you know his energy levels are
really scattered so like he doesn't know
what he's saying
um his his premise here uh about
capitalism the the that this man even
dare say anything about capitalism when
his entire Administration is about
rejiggering the economy not free market
capitalism this has become crony
capitalism we protect some and not
others this is not the fault of Act of
capitalism the way it's designed the
free exchange of goods and competition
and some things will fail and some
things won't if you don't let certain
things fail then they will never fail
and then you will be rewarding the bad
guys the speculative people the risky
people by the way I shouldn't say bad
guys you could be speculative and risky
and and take great risks and sometimes
it really you don't need to be a banker
or someone involved in finances do this
someone who bungee jumps you're taking a
freaking hell of a risk
you're going to get a exhilarating a
ride if it works but if that thing snaps
you're in a lot of trouble but the
government can't magically save you at
that point uh Biden also he's God God
this man it's just incredible that this
guy has anything to do with anything
um he's trying to come up come up there
and basically be like you got nothing to
worry about uh because you know we've
got the FDIC here but the problem is
when the FDIC says hey we will insure
you up to 250 000 now you watching this
right now
might be like well that's pretty good I
don't have 250 000 in my account so 250
000 that's pretty good but these
companies that borrowed all of this
money from them or that put all their
payroll money you know they get money
from investors right so now they have
let's say a company it's not bringing in
any money but it's got a good idea now
they raise 50 million dollars now they
take that 50 million dollars and they
put it in this Bank the bank does all
this crazy stuff with it but they're
only insured 250. well now the
government is coming in and saying we
will protect that 50 million dollars now
I'm not even I'm not blaming any
specific person here because each
company is different and maybe some were
doing some responsible things and
everything else but the point is we take
banks that are too big to fail and then
we make them bigger that's what we did
in 2008 do you know that in 2008 uh one
of the things that they did I had the
the president the former president of bb
and t on the show years ago we'll find
this clip we'll play it for you tomorrow
that when the government came in and
bailed out the banks they forced the
banks who were operating uh within their
means to take the bailout money isn't
that interesting they didn't just say to
the banks that were struggling that had
done all the crazy stuff with real
estate and lending money to people you
know so you could buy a two million
dollar house if you were making 50 Grand
a year and you wanted to put one percent
down they forced Banks like BB T and I
believe Wells Fargo was the other one
who had acted responsibly not lent money
that they didn't have et cetera Etc to
take the bailout money and then they
made the entire machine bigger so that
is what just got bigger the machine just
got bigger right and Joe Biden the idea
somehow old Joe I have to explain the
basics to you uh that you can pump money
into these things and that will save the
economy no it puts Band-Aids on a
Band-Aid on a Band-Aid and we can keep
this Frankenstein monster going but
that's what we're doing
all that being said I will get to the
arguments for why you have to do it in
just a moment because there are good
arguments on both sides as I said but
he's saying that this is somehow a moral
hazard and what that does is it
incentivizes the banks to get riskier
with the decision making if every time a
bank screws up royally and by the way
again you can partly blame it on the
government for inflation and everything
else if every time a bank screws up we
come in and bail them out and the 250
actually means nothing the 250 means 50
million if you want or 100 million or
whatever they've got in there well then
what is the point of having private
Banks aha do you think that might be
what's going on here the government is
thrilled to be getting rid of these
Banks because the government would like
what
central control you think we're on to
something over here anyway uh it's a big
important day Biden got up to give that
speech and here he is taking questions
thank you God bless you and may God
protect our troops see in California Mr
President what do you know right now
about why this happened and can you
assure Americans that there won't be a
ripple effect do you expect other Banks
to fail Mr President
should all depositors be protected at
all banks
all right thank you everybody
um
I mean look there was no way in high
hell that they would have let him take
questions there they would have shot him
rather than had him go on one of his
extemporaneous crazy rants right there
but him slowly walking out slowly
closing the door behind them as the
questions began just the Optics of this
are ridiculous uh so look I've got
unfortunate enough in in the world that
I live in with the things that I've done
uh I know a couple decent people and I
bring them on the show sometimes and I
talk with them privately so I can help
formulate my thoughts for this show uh
Balaji srinvasen is a an American
investor he's originally I think his
parents were from India but he's an
entrepreneur and an investor he actually
was one of our First Investors in locals
this is this is a really great thinker
he's invested in some big things made
major money on it he was the co-founder
of council and he was the former Chief
technology officer of coinbase uh way
back when this guy is he's accomplished
and he's a forward thinker he had a
tweet that I think sort of explains how
we ended up here quite well he said
first the FED printed trillions then
denied inflation was happening then said
it was transitory then suddenly sent
rates to the Moon that crashed much of
the economy
debris to start falling this year thanks
real estate Blue States then pressure to
print will resume what he's getting at
there is this is a government created
problem and then the last line what will
be the solution the solution will be
that the government will need to print
more people will literally the
government created the problem and
people's people's solution will be we
just need more government we need more
regulation we need more regulators and
manipulation and all of those things
we've been through this this is a rinse
and repeat cycle of what we've been
doing this is just to print more money
situation so what is the correct
solution okay I'm going to try to give
you two slightly different arguments
here by two people that I completely
respect who I would love to have on the
show at the same time so Vivek ramaswamy
who you know he's running for president
he's been on the show a couple times uh
he is an investor
he has made hundreds of millions of
dollars in the market with startups he's
doing strive uh uh not strive yeah he's
doing strive the strive fund the strive
Capital which basically is a giant fund
that does not have ESG in it that does
not have diversity Equity inclusion his
fund puts money into companies with good
products having nothing to do with the
color of your skin or whether they're
for climate change or anything else his
book nation of victims explains a lot of
this really really fabulously anyway he
had a tweet here that I thought uh was
quite good so this is his take on it
I'll try to it's a bit long but just
bear with me here he said there's
something very ugly happening right now
VCS and startup execs who stand to lose
their deposits at svb are going out of
their way to push a narrative that
there'll be a bank run on Monday that's
today is If svb depositors aren't bailed
out by the government they're yelling
fire in the proverbial theater hoping
that everyone run runs and knocks down a
candle on their way out actually
starting a fire that may not otherwise
have existed they're skipping the fact
that svb's situation is unique a
staggering 89 percent of its deposits
were uninsured way higher than normal
Banks and they didn't hedge interest
rate risk which is a cardinal sin giving
the portfolio they had their real hedge
was to spend money to become popular in
the right influential Circles of their
own depositors pledging 5 billion
dollars in 2022 to sustainable finance
and carbon nutrient carbon neutral
operations to support a healthier Planet
maybe that hedge will pay off for their
depositors if the government bails them
out but that should rightly trigger and
occupy Silicon Valley of historic
proportions okay so the simple version
of that what he is saying is they were
running an operation there that had very
little to do with with what a bank as a
business should be doing which is oh
someone has come here and given us a
certain amount of money we can take that
certain amount of money and we can put
it in a whole bunch of different things
because we have our investors and we get
advice from certain people and we're
going to put some of it and invest the
uh we're going to put some of it in
Risky Investments some of it will be a
little more conservative and that way
when someone comes for all their money
even if we've lost some with risk we've
made money on some other things and we
won't have these big Bank runs and
everything else what he's saying is for
political purposes these people that
were Silicon Valley people so they're
mostly Lefty leaning people not all and
we'll get to one in just a sec but most
left-leaning people they did not invest
in companies that had good business
plans uh or who were actually building
good products they were focused on
environment and climate and diversity
and equity and inclusion and all of
those things and this idea that 89 of
their of the money that they brought in
was not insured meaning it was over the
250 insured portion is a crazy amount of
money to just be pushing out there with
no backstop on that okay so that's the
basic version they took risky but legal
Investments with uninsured deposits and
in the process they didn't account for
the possibility of the FED increasing
interest rates in the future which would
devalue the dollar I'm really trying to
do this in like the simplest kind of way
for everybody for myself included okay
so that's one take what he's upset now
by is that the government is coming in
to help now I want to show you a video
from David Sachs now you guys know David
sacks he was the former CEO of PayPal
he's been on this show many times I
think he's one of the most clear cogent
voices that we have in America
politically right now he also happens to
be an investor in locals uh he's been
really rabidly against the Ukraine war
for not only military and War purposes
but also for financial reasons and he's
the co-host of the all-in podcast here
he is taking a different with a
different take on what the government
should do and what it was going to do
Etc
the best case scenario would be that a
buyer would step in for Silicon Valley
Bank perhaps backstopped by the fed or
by the FDIC and they would basically
announce that all deposits are safe and
that the bank will reopen on Monday and
people can get their money out if they
want to that would be the best case
scenario I think that's what should have
happened last week when svb was buckling
I think the feds could have been much
more aggressive and they could have
nipped this problem in the bud they
didn't do it and now I think the
situation is we have to be concerned not
just about svb but I already know of at
least one other bank I don't want to say
the name but the runs have already
started so this is now we're now in the
early this is the regional bank or a
smaller Bank in yeah it's a it's a
regional bank and and then there's a
list of other ones
okay so without getting overly complex
here what what David sacks was calling
for there is basically what happened the
government did step in so it's not what
Vivek wanted and by the way I really
like both of these guys okay so so I'm
I'm actually just presenting their
arguments for you and then you can
synthesize them you can think about it
sleep on it whatever and I maybe I can
get them both on even at the same time
to discuss this further what he was
saying was if you let this Bank fail all
of these other banks these Regional and
more local banks everyone is going to go
oh we might have done this stuff too and
then their banks will start failing and
then once that happens they'll basically
be a contagion within the system and all
of these banks will fail vivek's
argument is this is sort of a unique
case and you just got to let them fail
we have to get to the pain point and
then we can start the reset what David
is saying
is if we do that we do not know what is
on the other side now the government
basically did what David wanted it split
the difference in a certain regard
because of what Biden said there that if
you invested in this Bank you're screwed
and if you were working at this Bank
you're screwed but we are going to make
sure that the money put into the bank
that is going to go to these companies
to pay all their people even though that
money in essence has disappeared that
that money Benito it's gone but the
government magically always has more
money that's the good thing about the
government I should be doing a
government program why am I trying to
earn money to spend it what a sucker
guys the whole thesis of this show is
that the real root of the problem is
that we have leaders in government right
now who politicize woke activism over
basic textbook fiscal responsibility
right that's the point that you had
these companies coming in saying art our
purpose
of of being an entity of being a company
is not to build
be the best
Paper Company the Dunder Mifflin let's
say
of paper but to be number seven because
we're going to be working on climate
issues or we're not going to hire the
best accountants to make sure the books
are looking good we're going to hire the
best black lesbian crippled accountants
so that we look nice on the outside and
over time the products start to fail for
example in December of 22 the government
passed a bipartisan 1.7 trillion dollar
Omnibus Bill to Ukraine while we were
having 40-year high inflation and
all-time high debt do you think any one
of us like who do you know anyone in
your life that was like Yay we gave
another 100 billion to Ukraine the only
one who I know like that was Mitch
McConnell and I don't know him
personally remember Mitch McConnell the
number one issue on Republicans Minds is
making sure that Ukraine gets the money
that it needs like what what are you
people saying uh Tucker Crossing you may
have heard of this guy he's a fairly
popular Cable News host from what I
understand he's on a Fox News Channel I
heard that somewhere also he had a good
take on what sort of drives this what
why does this stuff keep happening
here's Tucker
so just today Biden's top economic
advisor Cecilia Rouse addressed
reporters in the White House in the
briefing room about what had just
happened and she assured everybody that
the bank run we're watching is an
isolated incident no it's not a big deal
it's just this one bag it's not
connected to anything else at all and
the fact that this Bank failed just like
the fact that FTX failed has nothing to
do with the fact that the people who run
it spend a ton of their time doing
completely irrelevant crap
that had to do with politics and
changing American culture
he reassured by that well you should
know that Cecilia Rouse has been
thinking a lot about this when she
worked at Princeton which is a
University of New Jersey she wrote her
research agenda on
diversity equity and inclusion the title
is we're quoting diversity in the
economics profession a new attack on an
old problem svb and FTX for that matter
are just two of several major players in
the financial industry that have gone
under in recent months are you noticing
any of this
there was the bank silvergate more than
11 billion in assets there was a crypto
broker Voyager a billion in assets the
crypto fund 3ac 10 billion in assets
block Phi and a number of others on
Friday Wells Fargo customer supported
they didn't get their paychecks as
expected the bank says that was just a
computer glitch we don't really know
okay so you got to understand Tucker is
reiterating a point that I've made here
several times once these companies go in
with this ESG nonsense so you invest in
companies not because they produce
something worthwhile or valuable but
because they have your social justice
nonsense Incorporated in them as opposed
to creating something good the old days
my God
I made the best little Dave Rubin in
town and I'm gonna sell them and then
the bank goes well how many uh you know
how many crippled children are you going
to save by saving your Dave Rubin by
putting out your Dave rubin's there they
go well little Dave Rubin Little Dave
Rubin I'm gonna sell a little Dave Rubin
for seven dollars a little Dave Rubin it
cost me three dollars to make little
Dave Rubin and I'm Gonna Keep the other
four and that's how it's going to work
and they go well what do you mean you're
not going to give a little money to
climate change for little Dave Rubin and
go Little Dave Rubin doesn't care about
climate change
laughs
I could have also done that with
chapstick but little Dave Rubin was
closer to me
but the point is guys this is what they
do this is what they do if you bring in
people what do you think that these
people at these Banks once you're in the
diversity Equity inclusion Department do
you think all day long they're focused
on my God we would like to invest in
good things we'd like to make some money
we'd like to really do right by our
investors or all day long are they
concerned that trans people are doing
this and gay people are doing this and
black people are doing this and
everything else interestingly Rouse who
she's referring to there we showed a
little bit of a video of her before she
is the 30th chair of the Council on
economic advisors of the U.S while her
priorities are diversity equity and
inclusion as opposed to say I don't know
basic macroeconomic science wouldn't
that be like most of us took economics
101 in college did she ever take the
class or was she focused on Counting how
many black people were in the class
I think you know the answer anyway I
want to go a little further with Tucker
because he handed it to Janet Yellen
over this thing and this woman remember
inflation isn't happening it's
transitory oh it's here and I
guarantee you her hair is a little wider
this morning but go ahead
what is very clear is that we're
witnessing something serious happening
in the finance sector in other sectors
of our economy we don't know where any
of this is going we're certainly praying
for the best we don't want to see
Hysteria but if you're the treasury
Secretary of the United States you would
be very concerned you'd be paying really
close attention because that's your job
but Jenny Ellen is not paying close
attention
she's not worried about it because it's
in this country she's worried instead
about funding the pensions of Ukrainian
government workers she flew to Kiev the
other day to tell us that and as always
Janet Yellen is highly focused on her
core duties as treasury secretary that
would be Equity climate change and
abortion
the Biden Harris Administration has made
racial Equity a centerpiece of our
economic agenda Roe v Wade in access to
reproductive health care including
abortion helped lead to increased labor
force participation President Biden and
I feel the same way too believe that
climate change is in existential threat
that absolutely must be addressed the
message I bring you from President Biden
is simple America will will stand with
Ukraine for as long as it takes here you
have the second biggest bank failure in
American history the biggest since 2008
the second largest failure in our
nation's history and they're yammering
on about racial Equity really
really yeah really Tucker I'm with you I
can't believe it either other than I can
believe it that line that Janet Yellen
says racial Equity will be a centerpiece
of our economic agenda
lady you were just supposed to carry the
one that's it okay add it up
give us the numbers
right that's all you had to do but
racial Equity I actually believe her
because at the end I think she wants us
all to be poor equally she wants white
people to be as poor as black people as
poor as Asian people and as poor as
Latino people and then we shall have
peace that was Palpatine line you got
that kind of got it uh but what else is
this government focused on because
obviously racial Equity at the core of
our economic policy is very important
they're also trampling all over our
first amendment here's a it's a bit of a
jump on the Segway here but I could not
do the show today without showing you
this video Eric swalwell
the farting
gas-filled buffoon that is Eric swalwell
congressman from California he is
horrible he has slept with a Chinese spy
everyone knows it uh here he is wanting
to pass a law to ban troops our troops
who defend our nation and who defend our
freedoms he wants to pass the law to ban
our troops from watching Fox News
I think about our troops and I've been
all over the world and have visited our
troops uh in some of the harshest places
and nothing makes them feel more like
home uh than their access you know to
American television programming in a
popular channel is Fox News and again I
don't want to get in the business of
telling troops what they can and cannot
watch but if you have a news station
that a court is going to rule uh is uh
in its evening hour uh you know
perpetuating this and misinformation uh
I don't know if I disagree with both
vets who are saying uh that we need to
take a look at uh you know how this is
being broadcast to our troops I hope
that's an incentive for Fox News to
clean up uh its evening hour uh you know
starting with uh Tucker Carlson and
going late into the evening with Laura
Ingram they all spun and told these lies
so I don't think we're out without
complete recourse
yeah you guys get it look
he is the liar MSNBC puts more lives on
a daily basis than than is almost
humanly possible every single one of the
lives verified people on both sides Kyle
Rittenhouse is a white supremacist
Jessie Smollett being hung all of the
Russia hook collusion Roger by laptop
they've lied about absolutely everything
but that Dirtbag mfer what he wants to
do is make sure that our troops our tree
just said it nothing makes them feel at
home more than watching popular TV and
then he's like in one of those popular
channels is Fox News so I want to take
it away from them what an evil
anti-American anti-first Amendment piece
of you know what I'm really trying to be
good today for this later in the
afternoon show for some reason I find it
easier to curse in the morning horrible
human horrible human but these people
they are all they have all drunk the
Kool-Aid so they see propaganda right in
front of them and they think it is real
that's why we are the red pilled ones
and it's a little tougher being red pill
because you're walking around with a
whole bunch of robots all the time going
what what is wrong with you people
here's msnbc's Chris Hayes telling us
that the New York Times isn't a liberal
newspaper I'm gonna bash my head against
it how long is this clip it's like 12
seconds I'm gonna bash my head against
the desk for 12 seconds I'll be back
now I disagree vehemently with Tucker
Carlson's assessment of bias in New York
Times it is not a liberal paper
his point though that the political
right lacks credible journalism is well
taken
ah oh
screwed up the timing on that one I
can't bash my head against the desk for
12 seconds I got kids downstairs I have
other responsibilities that clown these
people are insane like in he doesn't
think the New York Times if you mean
that they're socialists that they're
past liberal right they're past
Progressive if you mean that they're
socialist or communist you Muppet you
fake glasses glasses wearing Muppet then
I suppose I agree with you but otherwise
no no no no no no
no anyway here's CNN's Jim Acosta asking
fauci fauci's back through we're just
wrapping you up with like a whole bunch
of BS at once to just kind of tie this
thing together here's a cost to ask and
fouchy about Elon Musk
and the other thing I wanted to ask you
is you know you've been vilified on the
far right I know you know that
um and we've seen Elon Musk tweet that
his pronouns uh he's the owner of
Twitter that his pronouns are prosecute
uh fauci others in the GOP have talked
about arresting you and Prosecuting you
um for your handling of code what's your
response to that your response to musk
and what has that been like for your
family
well I mean there's no response to that
craziness Jim I mean prosecute me for
what what are they talking about I mean
I wish I could figure out what the heck
they were talking about I think they're
just going off the deep end
well I got a couple for you fauci we
could prosecute you for lying under oath
uh for telling people privately that
they don't have to mask and that they
don't work while you were publicly
pushing for policy that masks do work uh
by basically making up lockdowns the
whole theory behind lockdowns which was
unproven and untested and completely
made up uh maybe a little bit of that
maybe the fact that your NIH through
ecohealth funded the gain of function
research at the Wuhan lab could we
prosecute you for that or how about for
just being a smug douche I don't know if
that's in the law anywhere could one of
you we don't have a league I'll get if
any of you are legal experts is is
somehow if you're constantly a smug
douche can we something funny about the
word douche don't you think if you're a
smug douche over and over and over again
can we eventually arrest you is there is
there a citizen's arrest you know what I
mean could somebody just go up to him at
the supermarket
I'm arresting you put down those apples
we're arresting you into citizen's
arrest you've been a smug douche for 652
days in a row speaking of smug douches
here's Adam Schiff
and Adam kinzinger I forgot I didn't
realize they're both named Adam that's
pretty good these two atoms with
Anderson Cooper and listen again
everything they say is it's not it's not
mostly the reverse of Truth it is 180
the reverse of Truth here you go
yet the power of repetition uh is such
that you know people like Tucker Carlson
who know they're lying to the public can
convince tens of millions of people of
those lives uh I I tell you it's been
really uh Illuminating to me about other
periods of History where you had other
Liars use a powerful megaphone and
convince millions that they can't
believe what they've seen
Adam Schiff and Adam kinzinger who led
all of the lies about Russia collusion
who led all of the lies about the hunter
Biden laptop who led the lies about
January 6 that are crumbling in real
time right now
they dare accuse Tucker of being the
liar I am not sitting here as Tucker's
lawyer telling you that he is perfect
right but he's pretty damn good and he's
a hell of a lot closer to the truth uh
than these people shifts should be
embarrassed like fauci to go out in
public the level of shame that this
person should have and kinzinger should
have it is off the charts these people
should not they should be not listened
to how how is it that Anderson Cooper
not that he's any Bastion of greatness
but how is it that he's like you know
what we're going to do on our show
tonight I'm going to get Adam Schiff
who's been wrong about everything for
four years can we get him is he
available and how about kinziger he's
always been wrong about everything
forever could we get him and we'll put
him on together and see what happens
like
anyway here's Jane Fonda talking about
killing people
according to NYPD crime was up by more
than four percent overall in in New York
City in January murders were down
slightly but robberies assaults burglary
car theft all up what action are you
going to take over in this rise in crime
uh in these in these other categories
besides murder and rape
Public Safety is absolutely my number
one priority it's top of mind for all
New Yorkers and I'm working closely with
mayor Adams to help provide resources to
protect people in the subway supporting
our NYPD and their work all right sorry
guys that was completely my fault you
see what they've done to me I'm so
worked up about the show today and
fiscal responsibility which I think is
the sexiest topic that I threw to the
wrong clip so let's just review that
clip for a second there's Don Lemon
being like hey hochul you're in charge
of New York uh the whole place has
fallen apart crime blah blah blah
man what does this is that a facelift
what is that
my number one responsibility is the
people at safety sure everybody's being
killed you know when I was in New York
City last week just called you know was
a week ago for Gutfeld I was wandering
the upper west side and then like two
hours after I left right on 63rd and
West End which is a completely nice area
a woman was raped in a vestibule while
walk while going into her apartment like
it is not good in New York these people
are absolute clowns and now I don't know
that I can give it a better uh intro
than I gave it before here's Jane Fonda
on The View now they're going to be
talking about abortion here but what I
also want you to note speaking of Kathy
hocha like this the amount of I did my
research the amount of facial filler and
Botox at this table with these women
they set a Guinness Book of World
Records it will be in the next edition
of the Guinness book take a look
we have experienced many decades now of
having agency over our body of being
able to determine when and how many
children to have we know what that feels
like we know what that's done for our
lives we're not going back I don't care
what the laws are we're not going back
the women will rise up that's the
activist that's James speaking and then
and she probably will get a Nobel Prize
it is the truth I'm not going to do it
and protesting what else do you suggest
it's not a miraculous what did you say
murder she's
wait a second she's just not don't say
that oh you don't know they'll pick up
on that yeah she's just kidding it's
well let me talk to you about it
let's move on and talk about Jane's
activism
look I don't want to make a big stink of
whether she was joking or not like she
was joking to some degree and then they
try to get her out of it and then she's
slyly with the little eye roll does this
thing like oh I'm not joking does she
really want to kill people who don't
want abortion actually I think it's
possible I really do like if your whole
rationale is I want to kill babies then
maybe you would kill some people maybe
but the point is if this was flipped in
Reverse if the view ever had a pro-life
activist on and they were like well what
would you like to do with people who
provide abortion abortions and they were
like kill them murder that would be good
that person would never be on television
again their all of their gigs would be
canceled they would be banned gone
canceled adios amigos so I just wanted
to show you a little bit of that
hypocrisy uh to end this whole thing
with but before we end as you know I
like to give you some possibilities some
some positive options some outlook for
the future that makes sense uh because
if we just continue to prioritize woke
lunacy over basic fiscal responsibility
and basic economic science we are going
to be far worse than we are right now
like I don't know what would happen but
it would be worse we will just continue
that slow descent so what is the
solution
the solution well I thought this was
interesting you're not going to believe
this this is actually wild guys I'm
going to show you a CNN clip right now
uh this is a CNN contributor by the name
of Scott Jennings I think he might be a
former Kentucky Congressman if I'm not
mistaken uh actually making sense on CNN
this is mind-blowing
if this if you're sitting on the edge of
your seat I want you to lean back don't
fall off your chair
someone on CNN actually making sense
I don't know I hope every Democrat runs
on this I hope they read the poll and I
hope they run as as woke as they can get
in the next election because I think
it'll endure to the benefit of
Republicans and conservative candidates
when you take you know your your social
cultural viewpoints as Extreme as they
may be and use that to suppress basic
common sense and basic American values
yeah you want to run on that by all
means I I I wish you well
as you can see he was former Special
Assistant to Bush
um
what they're referring to there is that
there was a poll that said that most
Americans think that woke which is
obviously somewhat of an amorphous term
right because everyone's sort of
defining it differently I think you guys
here we have we have a basic
understanding of when I say woke what it
means right but like it's used in a lot
of different contexts by a lot of
different people some people say I'm
woke as a positive thing I go oh I
don't want to go anywhere with you got
to get out of here but here he is making
some sense I I agree with what he's
saying that let the Democrats go all in
on woke and you can already tell that
something's starting to shift and you
can tell it by that Bernie clip remember
the Bernie clip from a few days ago
where Bernie was on Real Time with Bill
Maher and he refused to back Equity
instead of equality because they know
it's not polling well there's actually
internal data on this now they know that
Americans like equality when it is
clearly and calmly explained to them
they don't like Equity meaning uh equal
opportunity well they like equal
opportunity they don't want equal
results your hard work a little luck all
of the the stuff of life gets you to
somewhere in the end and that somewhere
might be above somebody below somebody
whatever but we don't want to end up in
the same place it's counter to
everything that America has been about
for 250 years so it is odd to me that
woke is still polling positively but I
say let the Democrats run on it keep
running on woke and let's see what
happens vote in so what do we have to do
we have to vote in non-woke leaders and
we have to get the woke people out of
office and out of all of the government
institutions and then you actually just
do some basic stuff how about we
prioritize fiscal responsibility basic
math instead of diversity Equity
inclusion instead of sjw and ESG and all
the other acronyms how about we just get
back to earning spending and living your
life without a giant government
albatross around your neck at all times
and here's a beautiful video I saw this
over the weekend this is a young lady
named Savannah Hernandez she works for
Turning Point USA and one of the things
that she does
she goes to college campuses and she
talks to college kids about what they
think now obviously as a turning point
uh representative she is a conservative
or at least certainly conservative
leaning I think she's pretty libertarian
we're going to get her on a Friday panel
I already talked to her about it but she
went to a couple college campuses to ask
white students about their white
privilege and watch this beautiful
moment of her deprogramming this care
right in front of his eyes
I I grew up as a white man and you
you're the exact opposite you know and
so it's like my experiences are going to
be different from yours how come I think
uh you know there's a thing of like
white privilege uh what privileges do
you have that I don't have oh see that's
a question I keep asking myself because
like in this day and age like all the
laws I say all the laws you know I'm
it's hard to speak on something I'm not
fully knowledgeable of so like I'm sorry
if I like make a mistake in saying this
but it's like
like uh
don't you think it's a problem in
society when white people think that
they have more privileges than brown or
black people
yeah and I think that's sort of the
agenda that's pushed off because
personally it's like not that I think
I'm more privileged than anyone else
because I had to work to get where I was
and that's like why do you have that
mentality immediately where you you know
kind of apologize to me like let's talk
about privilege let's talk about I'm a
white man in America so we could have
grown up differently why is that your
first initial reaction to me as a brown
woman
see there's a kind of conversations that
I love having
um and I think it comes from a place of
like
uh I wouldn't say caution but like in
this day and age people are so quick to
judge and react and cancel and so I
guess it's that that like caution to go
into an interview like this on like I
don't know where we're at but now I know
where we're at and I can like uh go for
real
guys that's beautiful and that is a
white pill and that is Hope and did you
get at the end there when she really
turned it on him he didn't know why he
said it he didn't know why he said it
it's the cudgel of cancellation that
they have held over everybody's head you
will put empathy and really faux
unknowing empathy for other people above
everything including yourself you don't
know why but you know why you'll do it
because otherwise they will destroy you
well that's one less dude that they're
going to destroy because he just got it
so they may come after him I don't know
what school he's at I have no doubt that
the activists will come after him and
blah blah blah but as he said he had to
work it wasn't so easy for him and even
if it was easy for him even if his
parents were multi-millionaires should
he be punished because of that
we all know the answer we all know the
answer we got one more for you guys
since everybody in mainstream media and
in our government is going after Tucker
Carlson uh Tucker Carlson I thought we'd
let him finish up the show for us uh he
was talking to the nelk boys do you know
the milk boys they're uh they're on the
computer very big with the young people
uh and uh he talked about freedom and
what it means and the ability to
question things and not always trust the
government because apparently whether
you're Adam Schiff or you're Eric
swalwell or your Adam kinzinger or some
dingbat host on CNN Tucker Carlson is
Enemy Number One and from where I sit it
seems like he's just asking the right
questions
why wouldn't you want all the
information you can get and by the way
if you're an adult citizen why don't you
have the right to all the information
you can get like when did we give that
up first of all I can like or dislike
anyone I want okay
I'm 53. I've earned that right I can
like anyone I want that is not a crime
my opinions are not a crime they never
can be a crime in a free country a B I
have a right to all the information I
need to make an informed decision about
whatever the issue is that's democracy
right if they're like oh you're not
allowed to know that really why am I not
because I might arrive at a conclusion
that's different from the lies you're
telling me actually I want that
information yeah who do you think is
telling the truth or at least sort of
approximating the truth like kind of in
the orbit of Truth is it Adam kinzinger
and Adam Schiff and all of these people
or is it Tucker Carlson who's going you
know I'm allowed to think for myself I'm
allowed to question what you say and I'm
allowed to take note when you lie to me
over and over that maybe you're not the
most trustworthy people
I'm pretty sure it's Tucker you're
allowed to associate with who you want
you're allowed to question things you're
allowed to think for yourself that's
what the whole purpose of this freaking
country is and that's what's being
assaulted when they assault Merit and
they assault thought and decency and all
of those things and they lie and they
lie and they lie that's what they're
assaulting
the only way it stops is if enough of us
stop participating in the lie to Loosely
quote Alexander souljahnitzi we have the
right to know guys where our money is
being spent otherwise we wouldn't be
able to be informed enough to vote out
the leaders that wastefully spend it in
the first place you have a right
to something close to truth
that's what we'll keep doing around here
I like this three o'clock thing maybe
maybe I'm a little sharper around three
o'clock I think it's because I had lunch
I had a little chicken wrap with some
spinach before I got here
seem to have done the trick guys it's me
Monday over at the Reuben report locals
Community here's the one that I put up
which is sort of perfect for today
journalism in the old days it was
speaking truth to power with the people
behind you and now it is talking down to
the people with the powerful people
behind you uh we got tons of other memes
in there if you want to join us
reubenreport.locals.com and by the way
that's where I'll be doing a post game
show in about 36 seconds thank you and
goodbye
white men privileged man who played
men's sports
these statues will be torn down when I
become Prime Minister of Toronto and we
will replace them with all trans
athletes so this is going to be Leah
Thomas right here
we are on the unseated native territory
of the Mississauga and this building
should be torn down
[Music]
these are statues of white men they do
not deserve to be on the streets of my
city not in my Toronto we're getting rid
of white people here we uh because we
see them as domestic terrorists that is
what Jordan Peterson is become trans get
a tax break
mayor of Toronto every other candidate
[Music]
foreign